[Music]
so it's a huge crowd which is lovely at
this time of the day you can come closer
by the way there's gonna be a little bit
of life coding so probably like it
should be large enough but you know we
have so much space in the front rows
come on don't like highs in the back I'm
not gonna ask you questions I totally
will ask you questions No
so yeah thank you very much rollin for
the introduction I'm Martin Schmidt head
of engineering and archaeologic doing a
little bit of everything in the last
couple of month we started off with the
tool like this this is in a browser so
you could build and show interiors and
like offices houses whatever in your
browser and also like walk through them
furnish them and also do like VR
experiences in your browser based on
that VR I'm also Google developer expert
for web technologies and polymer so
that's that's something that I kind of
want to bring to everyone help them I
want to help you all to build better
stuff on the web and if you have any
questions I'm happy to help if I can't
answer them I'm gonna find you someone
who can answer them I also work with the
Mozilla community and the web standards
community so I try to encourage everyone
like did you for instance know that all
the w3c specs and stuff are on github
and you can actually collaborate by
opening issues or pull requests and
stuff so definitely check that out the
next time you see something where you're
like I don't think this is a good
decision bring up your comments with the
standards bodies because we all need
your input if if we developers want
better api's we have to give feedback to
the browser vendors so now comes the
boring part of the presentation which is
the introduction to all this because we
kind of want to go right into VR but
let's you know go over a few things that
make it more like reasonable and put
things into context so first things
first there's a lot of abbreviations
around there acronyms overload right so
we have like virtual reality we have
augmented reality we have
XR like x-reality what mixed reality and
then what else is there right so how do
these relate to each other so let's
start with something that is probably
not too new has been around since the
1960s actually when the first couple of
experiments started it's virtual reality
virtual reality is basically
constructing a virtual space that the
user is in so we are basically
completely ignoring the real world
around us we're completely shutting it
out and building our own little virtual
space what you can use and wander around
then there's augmented reality which has
become more of a buzzword recently
especially with Apple and Google putting
out a our core and they are KITT
respectively actually a Arkady's apple
and a our core is Google there has been
experiments with like markers before
that but now you can actually just use
your phone you don't need special
Hardware anymore you can just use a
phone that supports these two like SDKs
or platforms and just tap on something
and then it figures out where in space
you are so that's pretty cool and the
difference is that we are not shutting
out the world we are using the
environment that you are in and adding
something to it we augment it so for
instance you can say one of the first
apps that were probably relatively
popular in Switzerland at least in
Switzerland we have mountains as you
might know and the question and
sometimes is especially for like someone
who's emigrated interest with sidin like
me is what mountain is that so I would
basically bore my friends with friends
to death by what mountain is that aha
mountain is that like a freaking six
year old and with this augmented reality
what you could do is I could hold up my
phone my phone figures out here's where
I am this is where I'm pointing at so
looking at an database of moms and their
positions and basically triangulating I
show you this is that amount this is the
Duke pizza for instance or whatever like
this is warm blonde and you can
basically just like use that it augments
my view of reality by embedding
information into the surroundings that
I'm in at the time all of this is
encapsulated when we talk about both we
don't have to say VR and AR we can say
mixed reality or XR for some reason
so basically it all encompasses both
things that you can also have like other
things you can for instance
hypothetically have VR but embedded
video feed of some other space so then
you would have to be a likely they have
a tiny little bit of virtual reality
with the tiny little bit of like
augmented reality so you can mix them
together so basically when you hear
these terms you should now know that if
I talk about mixed reality or XR I mean
either virtual reality or augmented
reality most specifically VR and AR are
not excluding each other they are not
like competing in the same space there
are two different things
so a lot of people came to me in the
last like year or so and asked like
Martin do you think AR is gonna like
kill VR or VR is gonna kill a AR and
like hey do you think carrots will kill
potatoes because it makes no sense to
ask this question really it's not a dumb
question it's just like we haven't done
a good job explaining this and luckily
clay beaver from the Google VR team has
a wonderful explanation so basically in
virtual reality what we do is we take
you somewhere else
we are constructing a new reality that
is not the reality that you are in right
now so while I'm on stage if I go into
VR I could be on a beach which I would
really enjoy I could be on a really
really high mountain which I would not
enjoy because being on a high mountain
in t-shirt and shorts is usually not a
good idea
I could be under the sea which I would
probably also not enjoy because I have
to breathe somehow so yeah basically
what it is it is a teleporter it takes
the user using virtual reality somewhere
else it can even be like a Fantasyland
from Alice in Wonderland it doesn't have
to be a real place it can be anything
that I make up they are on the other
hand brings some information bring some
data to me so I'm not teleporting
somewhere else I'm still on stage but I
get an additional information for
instance maybe if I had like magical
goggles like I don't know Google glass
hololens or whatever they could tell me
I don't know the your favorite
Backstreet Boys song or something like
that or maybe I have an app that allows
me to put different things here like
have to
and fake you know virtual people here
sitting here having a panel discussion
or something like that so basically it
brings something to me so it's like
magic x-ray goggles it shows me
information that I'm not seeing normally
like x-ray goggles would show me
something that you know is under the
surface they are can surface information
that I'm not having by just using my
natural senses so this is the difference
and now it should become clear that
they're not competing they are come
they're basic aliy completing each other
or like complementing each other really
nicely because basically there's two
different use cases and they're
completely different one is bringing
information to me in the situation that
I am right now and you could say like
basically Google Maps as a augmented
reality application in the broadest
sense because it tells me where to go
right so it gives me information that I
don't have at the moment
whereas VR takes me somewhere else
biggest difference so what's the
landscape of we are like at the moment
so what is the kind of like the market
looking like so we have the HTC vive for
instance this is like more or less like
a high-power sports car you have these
little trekkers here and here you have
to put them up it's a little hassle to
set that up because you have to
literally like bring it on the wall or
put it on tripods or something but then
you can move along in the room and the
the trackers track you so you actually
know where in the room you are so you
can walk around in a virtual room which
is like super cool you have two
controllers with lots of buttons and
touch pads and stuff so you can really
nicely interact with your virtual
environment however that comes as a
prize and the price is quite expensive
and it's more or less the same in
dollars probably and then we have this
one this is different oh by the way this
one requires a computer that is strong
enough to actually power so you need a
gaming pc or a gaming laptop so that
laptop is probably around $1000 as well
so like you have to add that on top then
we have this one this is different first
things first it is like untethered you
have no cables here you put your phone
in and you put that thing onto your head
and off you go
however there has a downside that this
thing does not know we're in the room I
am so it doesn't it can't tell this
is different than this position yes sure
it has gyroscopes and stuff but they're
not accurate and fast enough to actually
do this kind of tracking in a room scale
so it's gonna get like imprecise and
when something doesn't add up in your
brain then you're gonna vomit which is
not a nice experience so this one the
only thing you can do is you can look
around the space there you're standing
or sitting but it comes as a lower price
it's around $100 maybe even less these
days but you also have to have a samsung
phone that is compatible with it this is
the gear VR from Samsung there's other
headsets as well I'm just picking a few
of them that's like daydream there's a
oculus rift all these exists somewhere
on the spectrum then we have this any
guesses on the price five Google
cardboard is around five dollars it's
like if you'd ship it from China it's
probably like two dollars really but it
also has the downside you don't have
like any buttons any controllers
anything and you only have the
orientation so you can only look around
but it works with most phones not all
phones if you have a potato phone os
then that's gonna be a bad time if you
have a Windows Phone moving on so the
mark kids in 2016 I still haven't seen
numbers for last year so I'm waiting for
the numbers for last year I was
basically like frantically checking
Google like are the numbers out for 2017
they're not okay fine I'm gonna go with
the numbers for the previous year 2016
so here we see how many of these devices
have been sold and you see like oculus
rift is around like 450,000 HTC vive
around like 489 500 thousand devices
PlayStation VR a little over 600
thousand devices daydream that just came
out this year so it's a little bit like
comparing apples to oranges because
daydream basically came out in q3 of
that year so they'd only got like two
quarters instead of the full four
quarters so it sounds like a few hundred
thousand devices and give er that has
been around the longest probably
together with oculus rift has been
around like a couple of million 2.2
million devices sold and so you can you
can draw conclusions from this so if you
think about it this is like the high-end
VR experience you have to have a gamer
PC
like really strong graphics engine in
there you have to set up the room for it
and you have to like buy this hardware
that is I think the rift is now like
$300 or $400 or something like that the
HTC survive still a little more like 700
600 $700 and these require a bunch of
effort and you really have to really
really want it because you have to like
buy hardware for it and then we have the
the mobile VR here and you can tell
about the gear VR that Mobile is
probably the thing that people are ok
with and like around 100 bucks is what
they are ok with spending for and then
surprisingly game consoles I just have
that in for the you know for the fun
conclusion that gaming consoles
apparently are also something that
people want to invest in for new gear
and for so this looks like give yards by
far the most popular player and the
market has been the most popular player
in the market in 2016 can you tell me
which one is missing here a cardboard so
why did I forget that well I didn't
forget it it's just it's changing the
graph a little so we had and that's like
estimated numbers like that's a
conservative estimation because a lot of
devices that are not technically
cardboard are actually cardboards like
you can get like plastic versions of a
cardboard which is not really counting
towards this number but we get like 82
I'm sorry what what is the number right
it's - my name is eros I keep getting
confused yes it's like 80 something
million devices out there so you could
say yeah
the high end is where I go for this is
what I should build for because you can
build amazing experiences but then your
users are less likely to have them so
what we have to keep in mind is we are
at a stage and this is probably still
true today with its changing but we're
still not there yet that the market is
mostly low-end we are explorers which is
cool because we actually haven't figured
out how to do we are like what we can
all do with we are in total like we
haven't even under
stood what the medium can deliver so far
and the same goes for ARS was basically
XR is unexplored territory so we need
some time to basically build stuff and
try things out and we can do that
because users are willing to is to spend
a little money to try it out with us but
we have to understand that the
capabilities are the minimum
capabilities we're not having like two
controllers and room-scale tracking
where can I go oh my god no we are at
the very very beginning so bear in mind
that most people are actually running
card boards these days still and I think
the web is the best platform to start
exploring for the simple reason that the
web as web developers we have learned to
not expect much from the devices we are
on we don't know where our browsers
running could be a fridge it could be a
watch it could be a potato who knows
right if it has a browser it can run the
web so unlike native developers who are
like no no no no no I know the screen
sizes like this and I remember the day
when the two different screen size
iPhones came out and the iOS Department
in a company that I worked for at the
time just went bananas like two screen
sizes who can deal with that right we're
gonna need the next two months to
actually factor all our application
layouts and I'm like how's the web team
doing we're like what oh we're done
solved so the same goes for VR because
we don't know what kind of device we're
having and even if we would know what
kind of device we're having there's a
lot of assumptions we can't make the
controller's from the wife you have two
controllers so I can totally do like oh
yeah the you start the game by dragging
something open with two controllers
that's cool but the controls are
wireless so they have to charge every
now and then so imagine the experience
of a user having one thing in the
charger base somewhere and then going
like I'm gonna play this game start the
game by dragging with two hands it's not
working right it's not a good experience
so basically we know how to deal with
responsive capabilities we have to deal
with what we can build and then
basically enhance until we reach the
level of the capabilities of the
hardware that we're running on and I
think the web is perfect for that and
everything that has a browser is able to
basically display content so we can
figure out a way to actually make all
our content respond
so for instance if you're coming to my
page with a Netscape Navigator I might
show you an image of a building instead
like a 3d image JPEG image your Netscape
Navigator can probably deal with that
cool and then if you're coming with a
more modern browser on a desktop without
any VR hardware or on a phone you get a
you get a 3d thing that you can like use
the mouse and keyboard or touchscreen to
navigate around and then you have a
button that you press and then you go
into VR and actually experience it as if
you were there that's pretty cool and
the web is basically the perfect
platform because it fits the paradigm so
well also the other thing is if I build
something for let's say vive or oculus
and then I build something and I is
let's say we have like a paint
application we can like paint something
and it's like I want to show this to you
and then maybe you want to add something
to it but then you have a cardboard
that's sad right so the only way to
actually collaborate or share would then
be to take my wonderful
three-dimensional scene and take a
picture of that and send you a picture
what's the point of that right so I
think the web is flexible enough to do
that but the question is can we even
like do 3d graphics on the web and the
answer is yes yes like WebGL has been
around since 2011 so most browsers are
supported opera doesn't support it
because it is usually relatively sorry
Opera Mini doesn't support it because
the VR sorry the 3d content is usually
pretty heavy on data and they don't want
that kind of data so they're not
supporting it so that you have to then
deal like okay right I'll give you the
image version here you go and that's
perfectly fine that's a reasonable
assumption so eighty six point five
percent of the global browser users
actually are capable of displaying 3d
graphics interactive 2d graphics in the
browser with no plugins required that's
pretty cool
but for vpr we need something else so
basically we do need actually WebGL to
render things to display 3d content but
VR or XR AR whatever needs something
else on top of that because we need
access to the devices we need access to
other information like the sensor
information the controllers we need all
that and that's exactly what the web XR
API and the web via our API before that
our
about so it gives us information is
there a headset available on the phone
it usually says yes because you have
cardboards so we can't really detect
that because you just put your phone
into a piece of cardboard but basically
the assumption is yes you have a headset
you could go into VR if you wanted it
also checks if we have information of
where in the room you are which you do
have on higher-end
devices or at least where you're looking
at at the moment the orientation of the
users field of view and it exposes the
controller so we can actually work with
this so don't confuse the vet VR or the
web xrap eyes as something that renders
2d graphics it does not it's the only
thing that it does is it gives us access
to the headsets and send like image data
there it gives us your orientation and
position of the user if available and it
exposes any possible controllers using
the gamepad API so that's pretty much it
it does not create 3d graphics we have
to do something else to get 3d graphics
and that was what WebGL is for I see
that often confused it is two different
things and this is also why it's so
responsive because we can start with a
3d experience so yesterday I had a
workshop on on VR at the center's our
shangri-la thing hotel and I was telling
like yes this is all VR already but
we're not going to test it because it's
just like putting up more time we would
need more time to like put it on the
headset and see if it looks good and
then go back to the computer and refresh
but because it is basically just sending
more information to us so that we can
actually change our our camera and stuff
like that we can just start with the 3d
experience and then enhance VR or a are
on top of it which is exactly what we
want because we can't expect that any or
like all of our users want to be in VR
all the time we don't know that now the
VIP VR API currently exists in version
1.1 2.0 coming out soon it's gonna be
renamed it's gonna be called the web XR
API the immersive devices API or
something like that so it's going to be
renamed because in version 2.0 we are
also addressing other mixed reality
concerns so we're also having a are in
there so we're moving from VR to broader
API that also supports a are in one set
of API so that you don't have to worry
about this which is nice but the AVR 1.1
VR 1.1 implementation is a little
lacking so far but what's cool is a few
browsers shipped it in production
already you have Firefox since version
55 shipping it Chrome for Android is
shipping it since Chrome for Android 59
it there are builds for chromium that
actually supported but in April we're
gonna ship or we're gonna problem
hopefully see web X our API is shipping
and Chrome regular on desktops as well
and holy moly
Edge's shipping them what right so yeah
I think that's like that's pretty cool
actually and not only them so like we
have seen edge we have Samsung internet
ships them as well
we have Carmel which is an experimental
browser from Facebook for oculus
definitely there's a chrome version
there's chromium chromium version
there's Chrome for Android shipping it
Firefox nightly has had it for ages
already and then there's the out one out
there servo server has support for web
excel as well and it's like super cool
because they are proposing in addition
to WebGL that makes it even faster and
better and nicer so that's pretty
exciting so we have it available on many
many many devices already and it's only
going to be more devices having this
support soon it's an open standard it's
not one company doing it all vendors I
hear that someone has joined the working
group from Safari so safaris team is
also on the working group they're not
signaling much yet but they are on the
working group which is a good sign I
would say but it's an open standard
where all the vendors are working
together to bring us in the set of api's
and they work together with oculus and
HTC and Samsung and all the other
companies that make headsets for us as
well so that's pretty exciting daydream
supports it as well so that's like
really nice and there's so much tooling
and a really strong community going on
like whenever you are having a question
you pop into a slack that is
like dedicated to epics are or one of
the libraries and everyone's like super
keen to help you there's like lots of
activity on Stack Overflow for all these
things lots of tutorials available so
you can get started relatively quickly
and it is just easier to create and
share a co-worker of mine has tried to
do it with unity and if this unity is a
perfectly fine tool unity is an amazing
tool for when you want to do what unity
does so if you're a game developer unity
is a great way to like quickly build a
game that is cross-platform that's
amazing it also exports to WebGL also
amazing however the developer cycle is
different because you code you compile
you take your head you run you take your
headset you pull it on you'll be like ah
damn I made a stupid mistake here you
put it down you go back to your computer
you like rewrite you recompile you rerun
you you know it takes a little while to
get that going the cycle is quite slow
actually so basically with the web you
just like write the code try it out oh
[ __ ]
fix it reload or [ __ ] still not good and
then you basically iterate really
quickly over that this is how you get
started no just kidding this is the
current another concern like everyone's
like super concerned that it's super
hard to get started that's not true
anymore so let's quickly try this I
tried this for like one minute and then
we're gonna have to have to move on
unfortunately so here I have a very very
boring website and I have the code for
this very very boring website but I love
to libraries I load Mozilla's a frame
and I load our libraries shameless plug
the 3d i/o library and I have something
here that looks suspicious right I have
something here called the a scene so
what can I do it will have an a scene
what I can do is I can create entities
basically this is like a stage this is
an empty stage and I can put something
on this stage I can say I want the
geometry to be a box and I want a
material that has a color red and now I
want to move this around on the stage so
maybe I say like and all of these
numbers are meters because that's the
metric system is a sensible system so I
don't want to move it to the left or to
the right I don't want to move it up or
down but I want to move it two meters
into the screen and now if i refresh
tada
there's a red box now
is not an exciting demo but I have a VR
button here so I can go into VR if I
would have a VR headset what was really
cool is a frame has a bunch of developer
tools so we get a full-blown 3d editor
as developer tools in here and that
allows me to like move The Box around so
I can move it here and there and then I
go back and hey look at that the box has
moved I can also change things about
this box so I don't want the box
I want a eye one day I don't know Taurus
not boom here we go we have a Taurus not
cool I don't know why you would want
that but go ahead I don't judge I don't
like the color so hey how about we make
this like blueish and I don't like that
it's not very metally and shiny I want
this to be shinier so I would go and
where's the metalness parameter here it
is here we go like we make this like
super shiny hey we have a shiny thing
now and you can basically build your
application like this you can explore
and what I can also do is I can go like
hey 3d IO people who did something for
me here so I can drag-and-drop something
that they build and just use it in my
application and if the Wi-Fi holds up
yes here we are
we can go back in and hey look at that
there's a weird tourist not in an
apartment that you might know we can
stand in Sheldon's spot just to you know
anger him so it's really easy to get
building really really quickly and you
don't have like I don't have to know any
math here I basically just just add HTML
tags and that's more or less it so I can
say hey maybe I want to copy out what I
just build in here so I can go here now
that's the light that's not what I want
it I can go here and I can just go okay
I want to copy this into my code now and
then I paste this into my code and if i
refresh Hey look at that
tada right so this is a really really
nice and fast way to get going and
basically start building things with no
big deal and no big pain so this is
really nice to get started and actually
you can build really exciting
applications with it you can build
production-ready applications with a
frame and that's actually pretty expand
so as I said this is not just VR and 3d
this is all
also going to have a our capabilities
thanks to the API broadening up in
version two to be an X our API so that's
exciting and you can do things like this
oh no the video is noting again anyway
this is a VAR application we have oh
look at that so here we are in Zurich
and we're basically plotting out where
the walls of this wonderful room are and
turned it on turn this is an open source
demo you can basically clone that from
github if you ask me for the URL I'm
happy to share that later on and then we
say we're door is so here's a door tada
and then there's another door tada which
is like a super weird living room but ok
let's go for it you get a floor plan
based on that and then you can say I
want to furnish this and using our API
you get furniture and you see like this
is actual this is a our we are in a real
world context and we're adding
information to it and this is on the
phone and this is on the browser so this
demo is actually available you need an
experimental browser right now but
that's gonna change in the near future
so here we go they are settled that's
gonna be an interesting talk on that by
a 180 and later today there's more stuff
out there there's the a-frames school
that gets you going with a frame really
quickly there's the up crater 3d dot IO
that's our thing that gets you like a
playground environment I actually do
videos together with my co-workers that
explain you all the important things or
the steps that you need to do we have a
bit of a blog shameless plug
there's an amazing group the WebEx our
Asia group on Facebook you want to join
them and basically connect to your local
community because they're awesome people
that want to help you face-to-face so
definitely go there and check it out and
also exchange ideas and stuff and I want
you to build stuff with this if this is
the one takeaway that you take away make
it the following if compute if the
computer is the bicycle for our mind
which accelerates our natural abilities
then VR is a teleporter and it can take
you anywhere and now is the time to
start exploring so build something and
show me what you build I want to see
what you all are coming up with and
there's so much to explore and thank you
so much for listening to me and coming
out this early in the morning
and I'm around the entire day for
questions and I'll be at the Mozilla
booth I think for questions as well and
definitely come talk to me and show me
what you build and I'm like super
excited to see what's gonna happen next
in this space thank you very much Thank
You Martha
[Applause]